[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh my goodness ladies and gentlemen
it's so good
it's just so good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
section of of the whole thing
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh dude I could not have planned
that better
wow that was not intentional actually
but we literally started the stream
right as it came to an end oh my
goodness it's just so good you guys it's
so good
I'm going with no lights tonight just
the lights in the background
some nights you know I just don't feel
like having the the bright shining light
in my eyes so
I know right you like this hoodie
what I love I think this is my favorite
part like the hooded part you've got
like the
different colors in there
I think there's a lion in there too
somewhere
yeah yeah there's like a lion All Around
The Edge I got that at the Wizarding
World when they uh first opened my first
trip there
my first trip there I picked that up all
right I'm just gonna go ahead and play
this again in the background I'm gonna
turn it much lower
but obviously we have quite a bit to
discuss guys in the world of Hogwarts
Legacy quite a bit to discuss oh yeah
not enough Gryffindor yeah then you got
you got the Gryffindor all down the arm
here too
man I mean what a couple of days right
this time last week I had anticipated
that in tonight's live stream we would
be discussing the character cards that
they revealed
talking more in depth about those and
which we may still we'll see how much
time we have and then they started
dropping all of these things
which are gifted our gifted membership
little icon is still broken
L window jumping in with the five no the
three no the five
versus said five then it said three then
it went back to five
L one with the five gifted memberships
also before I hopped in tonight uh Joel
sorry I missed you Joel Joel renewed
their membership
and then also ether renewed their
membership their tier one membership a
three-month streak for ether Joel with
the four month streak
how are you welcome and by the way it's
no longer welcome to Gryffindor it's
it's welcome to house rack and tour
oh wait wait I forgot something I forgot
something how are you
welcome to Gryffindor
[Music]
how are you welcome to Gryffindor
hello how are you welcome to Gryffindor
or got something
I forgot the wand too we should probably
do a wand but we unboxed this last time
so this is what I'm rolling with for now
oh and we put our headphones on
backwards there
[Music]
yeah yeah Clint knows what's up Clint
knows what's up the hammer so when you
become a member here
you are now officially a member of House
rack into her all of you congratulations
uh you just unlocked some emotes there
in the chat
discounts on the merch Dylan jumping in
there with a 20 Super Chat
so
Dylan says yo enjoy the amazing content
everyone hashtag Reese play Squad
hashtag 62 days
#house raconteur Dylan thank you so much
my friend yeah Dylan's schedule prevents
him from usually being able to watch too
far into the stream but thank you so
much Dylan for all the support all the
love and right I mean 62 days
62 days
so those of you who just got gifted a
membership Let's see we have
its philosophy gray Warden miles Kohl's
Templar gaming and Stefan or Stefan
Maybe
all just received gifted memberships
welcome welcome
Nico renewing his membership as well
remember for four months I feel good
is it only four months Nico I feel like
it's way more than that
I guess I've only been streaming on
YouTube for four months which is kind of
crazy to think see Nico and I go way
back guys Nico was
a fan from my my days on Twitch
fellow moderator here member of House
rack and tour
but uh Nico says welcome to house
wrecking tour everyone we have cookies
[Music]
wait where are they at I didn't get any
I didn't get any cookies
can I get some
oh man welcome everybody Welcome uh as I
mentioned in the beginning we have a lot
to talk about tonight so I'm gonna jump
straight into the shout outs that we
have here uh so we got ether here with
us tonight also Alicia what's up Alicia
both members of house wrecking tour
right there be Barbie as well Brittany L
another member of House wreck and tour
Clint Bart in the house uh Chiron or
Kirin c-u-r-a-n Dr Robo Panda Dustin
Quist Dylan elwin feathers Jake in the
house Jordan JP raven fire that entire
list right there we just read channel
members welcome guys thank you all for
hanging out on uh you got another
Tuesday here for retro reckon Tour live
We Got King Scar in the house Chris huff
and puff is back yo Chris Chris huffing
puff was our chat leader last time
most comments in the chat we'll see who
comes out on top this time I think I saw
a lowercase Logan in there as well yes
indeed both of those are members of
house rack and tour uh we got Luca we
got Matt Lewis wait the Matt Lewis is
that the Matt Lewis in the house
what's up Matt we got Mike here we got
Mr seven digit we got nagura Ravenclaw
also Neil Harrison both channel members
right there uh we said Nico already we
got outside Pete Plum Bob Kingdom member
of House track and tour uh Robin veldman
Shameless Hayden Sharon Cruz Sharon is a
member of House wrecking tour we got
psycho back in the house psycho welcome
back steffe is here tonight Stephy how's
it going
welcome we got the Christian gamer here
in the house tonight William bradseth
and then final channel channel member
that I see here extra whitey in the
house as well welcome guys welcome to
another Tuesday
which if you really want to put things
in perspective
if you really want to put things in
perspective let's see how many more
Tuesdays we have we have one two three
four five six seven eight
nine we are in the single digits on
number of Tuesdays you guys
single digits
not quite to seven yet Mr seven digit
not quite to seven
also Taylor Kim is here hopped on a
different YouTube account since my main
is a brand oh gotcha welcome super Niche
Channel member Aletha May Channel member
as well members of house raconteur
Jordan Crawford in the house eight weeks
guys right right
dude yeah we gotta start planning out
I mean I gotta start planning out what
we're gonna be doing on each of these
streams leading up to this I feel like
especially once I get down to once we
get to around five or so streams
once we do that yeah
psycho with a super chat psycho thank
you so much for your support of the
stream psycho says have you taken the
official house test that you will be
using in game on stream yet and if so
what were your results well I mean
I don't know if you guys can see what uh
what attire we're rocking tonight here
yeah I have psycho I didn't do it on a
live stream but I do have uh I do a
video up on the channel for it
so I've been I've taken so many sorting
tests over the years and
95 I'm I've always been Gryffindor there
was like once or twice where I got
Ravenclaw on some of them
but yeah we did uh on the uh on the
channel I have a video up where I did
the full Pottermore like all the
Pottermore questions
which is on a different website it's not
actually Pottermore but they pull all
those questions of course we're we got
Gryffindor
so that's gonna be my first playthrough
for sure
and then we got Ravenclaw Tyrell Rave
called Tyrell what is up also gifting
five memberships ladies and gentlemen to
the five new members of house Dragon
tour welcome
you are now a member
and there now we let uh John Cleese take
over
I could just like I was playing this
music on Spotify today on the way to
work
it's just so good man
it's just so good
Ravenclaw Tyrell as always thank you for
the support and love that you show the
stream and congrats to those of you who
just got one of those gifted memberships
so you're not subject to slow mode we
figured that out whenever you remember
you also get access to the fun uh little
Emoji which actually let me see if I can
use them from in here I can let's go
and thanks to your all's incredible
support we've actually unlocked quite a
few of them how are you so I'm just
gonna I just post them all right there
in the chat
here's what here's what I'm feeling
lately guys this is the one I'm feeling
hype train
hype train all aboard the Hogwarts hype
hype train express
all right so with that
it's time to get into the news
it's time to get into the news of which
there is a lot
there is a lot you guys
[Music]
and I feel like the best way to do it
might just be
oh man I think you're a wizard Harry
I've posted a lot of it on my Twitter
page
so I'm gonna have to scroll back a bit
because there's been so much
so much
since our last stream
so as I mentioned before I thought I
thought this right here is what we'd be
talking about this week which we'll see
how much time we get
but I don't think we're gonna have time
to talk about this one so we had four
total character cards as I've been
calling them for the new Hogwarts
professors that we're gonna have in this
game
so we learned their names as well we've
got Dina heckett actually you know what
I'll just pull up this video I'm not
gonna play the video but just so you
guys can uh not gonna play the sound but
just so you all can see the cards here
so we got ESOP Sharp
ESOP until I hear otherwise guys until I
hear otherwise that is the pronunciation
had a lot of people in the comments
being like
you know I know I messed up before into
pronunciations I know that
however ESOP just like from esop's
fables unless we hear otherwise our
potions master
um and then we had let's see I think I
have them all back to back right here
oh no I post them right here in the
beginning you're a wizard okay yeah so
then Abraham Ronan charms Professor we
knew about him already
Chandler had told us about him a few
weeks ago because we we spotted his name
in the Autodesk
presentation
so I don't know if that was that one was
intended or not but once we spotted it
they're just like okay fine yeah
he's Slytherin and he's your charms
professor so we got that one confirmed
it's Mr Moe renewing their channel one
or uh first time member of House
wrecking tour welcome it's Mr Mo thank
you so much you are now official
officially a member of House rack and
tour
so we had Abraham Ronan and I know I'm
rushing through these quick guys because
there's so many other things to discuss
so we had Abraham Ronan if you haven't
seen already go check out the video
that's got the full breakdown then we
have mirror belt garlic
herbology professor
which was a bit of a surprise I and
expect to go and several others we were
totally on board with that one being
Helen thistlewood
so a bit of a surprise on that one
um and also what do you guys think about
this
let me go right here
Oh I thought I had the I thought I had
the card up right there
and maybe it's later in the video
but anyway it's it's unclear if her card
says she is muggle born well it's clear
that it doesn't say she's muggle born it
says she was raised by Muggles so a lot
of people were wondering so wait is she
actually muggle born I assume yes and
talked about it in my video
but then
some somebody in the comments pointed
out well actually it doesn't say that
she's muggle born and I was like that's
a very good point it doesn't
it doesn't
uh it also has a line at the end I know
a lot of people were excited about this
that it seems to indicate
she could be an lgbtq Professor so
joining the joining uh our boy
Dumbledore
because it had a statement about which
um if another witch I'm trying to
remember where my I know I have them
later in the video I post the full cards
but uh if another witch were to come
along
and then we had
um Dinah heckett which Dina heckett was
actually the first one that they showed
but yeah I've got a full video breaking
those down you could check that out over
on the uh on the channel
and so I thought I had a I had tonight's
live stream was really planned around we
were going to discuss all of these
but because so many other things
happened
we're gonna have to we're gonna have to
see we might come back to that one later
so I'm gonna keep it up here so that was
on December 3rd it's literally been
three days that's it since I posted it
literally three days
and since then
we had the CCX oh my goodness didn't
mean to do that sorry the uh CC XP which
is kind of like the Brazilian Comic-Con
is the way that I heard it described
thanks to some awesome Hogwarts Legacy
creators who speak different languages
and I think Hogwarts like to see Brazil
here must even be there on the ground in
Brazil
but I think one thing we always have to
keep in mind guys and and I should know
this more than anybody considering our
audience and how widely
um like you guys are from all over the
place it's it's amazing we have people
from Australia from Spain from the UK
from uh there was Mexico Canada the US
Japan we had somebody from Japan I mean
and so I if if the audience here is is
global it's a reminder to all of us that
the Harry Potter audience is truly
global and so I think it's great that
they're doing stuff like this I mean a
lot of times we can kind of you know we
get in our own little Bubbles and forget
so it's like Ah that's you know it's not
really a big event at least not to us
they're probably not going to show
anything show anything too big right
wrong wrong wrong wrong very wrong
indeed so Hogwarts Legacy BR here
this was all also on I guess the evening
of December 3rd when they were posting
these so they showed a couple of new
bits of content here
and so let me make sure the sound is not
on so this one right here let's see what
the quality is really bad I'm gonna see
if I can find another that has a better
quality so this is what we saw from some
of these clips are from the music video
Yeah that's the music video which we now
have that one in full glorious 4K
footage
but in addition to the music there were
two other I would say fairly significant
reveals that we got okay that's it for
this one so piece of exclusive content
all right so I'm gonna back up here and
let's see let's go to this one now now I
want to hear more about this one because
I don't know if there's something Lost
in Translation here
because we're just using the Google
Translation right here but they said now
they're talking about the soundtrack
they said that the soundtrack brings a
lot of nostalgia which we know now many
memories are brought back by the game's
music the songs aren't just inspired by
the books and movies over 30 hours this
piece right here
over 30 hours
okay there's no way they're going to
have an actual like like the soundtrack
that they sell and put out there's no
way that's going to be 30 hours right so
I'm like what does that mean exactly is
that 30 hours of
recorded like I don't know and then
people are trying to kind of use that to
figure out what does this mean the game
is at least 30 hours
I I wouldn't read that into it because I
mean think about how many times in a
game if you're like going through a the
same area many times you're going to
hear the same music over and over
so that could mean it's even longer but
again I would be careful to read too
much into that one however I think it's
it's great news obviously it's it's
great news and then let's see this one
right here
Hogwarts will have secret passages
dungeons mini puzzles we won't be
limited to classes in addition to Hogs I
mean yeah okay yeah we knew that one
that was nothing new
um but then here here was when we
started to realize oh
okay
uh they're gonna show they're gonna show
something quite a bit more
that we weren't expecting here new
trailer
uh and so then I I can't remember it
wasn't in this tweet but at this point I
had seen someone talk about we can ride
grab horns grab horn writing confirmed
and then here we go this post right here
from Hogwarts Legacy Brazil this is
where we see it
this one is where we see it so I I
wanted to save this one but I'm just
gonna oh gosh oh gosh hold on sorry
listen to this crowd reaction man
listen to this crowd reaction from what
is such a small clip and again apologies
for the quality
we're going off Twitter quality here
my jaw my jaw dropped in this moment
dude
the animation on this
I mean are you
my jaw dropped when I saw this let's
watch okay let's watch it again
dude I mean just Spectacular One More
Time One More Time One More Time
I love it we'd already seen that little
bag whatever you want to call it Satchel
I don't know uh in one of the other
trailers with the moon calves right and
we already I've been saying how long
have I been saying guys where's the
sound coming from now please Twitter be
quiet I've been saying for so long how
important magical creatures were gonna
be in this game they're gonna play a key
role
over a year I've been saying this before
we even got the state of play and all
that
so we know we're going to be able to
rescue and nurse back to health
creatures and then like think about the
attention to detail with this right they
could have very easily just said okay we
want you to be able to summon grab horns
but they're just gonna like ride up out
of nowhere or they're just gonna appear
It's Magic it's the Wizarding World they
could just appear no no no no they're
like okay hold on we've got this thing
already established in The Wizarding
World Newt has this case right so why
can't this character have whatever this
thing is that we want to call it
and just how they're we're just running
along they pull it out open it up and
then just oh it's just it's so good man
has me so excited and there's another
shot it wasn't in this one clearly but
where you can see the the graph horn
like charging these goblins if they had
let this play all the way through I
might retweet that one here later I
can't remember if I retweeted that one
or not but as this plays through then
the grab horn charges and there's just
like some goblins standing out there
that they just trample over
and then here was another one which was
a scene that we've already seen bits of
in the trailer this one was with peeves
and what we assume is the librarian and
so they did some translation work here
for us and it seems like the librarian
uh is is reporting Sebastian to the
Headmaster it almost sounds like our
character could have put Sebastian up to
this though
a lot again all from translation I can't
say this for sure myself peeves of
course is the one who rats Sebastian out
uh but Sebastian does not give us up
here
so I don't know is this like one of
those scenarios where Choice can make a
difference right or is this like more of
a scripted thing we don't know but the
other big thing that we learned from
this is that it seems like the older
gentleman in the Sebastian Stark Legacy
trailer is his uncle
which would also mean Sebastian's sister
that is his uncle her uncle as well
so some people were thinking father at
first but uh I I still even though we
know Uncle now I still like the idea
that he's also the Game Keeper or
something I mean it makes sense that he
would be
since he's so close to the Forest right
so we got those two massive bits of
information and thanks to our um
Hogwarts Legacy b or no wait Hogwart
no s in there if you try to follow this
person uh for any of you Brazilians who
may be interested Hogwart Legacy BR not
an official account just a fan account
guys and then also Sly the aura who I
know occasionally Pops in our stream
here
Sly the aura was also doing some
translation oh yeah here it is here it
is I did retweet this one The Librarian
Is Telling Sebastian that peas was the
one who informed her he was at the
restricted Restricted Section and
demanding he tells her what he's looking
for
there might be another one on that too
oh yeah I forgot I forgot about this
piece
so they also made a comment and again
this is all from these rough Google
translations here an exclusive bag and
three t-shirts were raffled off so this
was at the event the physical version of
the game will come with a map
I'm sorry guys I know I'm missing some
comments some questions but I'm just
kidding I'm getting too excited too
excited about this stuff I promise I'll
I'll catch up on Chad here in a second
so for any of you who care about
physical goodies
uh hopefully we'll get confirmation on
this soon for U.S territories and UK and
well any other territories besides here
because we don't know this for sure I I
asked Chandler here I may this is a
public tweet I asked haven't gotten a
response
there's a chance they they I honestly
may not know yet
uh but I will caution you guys a lot of
times as I've mentioned before on stream
there are different
across territories with video games
there are often dip times different um
what's the word I'm looking for here
different I mean different things
included in the packaging different
retailers do different things like
Amazon France and Germany apparently
includes that special hat for the
digital Edition but they're so far it's
only Amazon France and Germany no other
Amazon
as I've shared with a lot of you before
on my stream the um I have the Metroid
dread collectors edition and the US
version only included the steelbook case
not the standard case
the UK Edition included the standard and
the uh the steel book so you just you
never know for sure I really hope it's
included though I re I really hope it's
included that would be an awesome
gesture
um man like like a cloth map could you
imagine if they'd done like a giant
cloth map in the collector's edition
all right I've harped on that enough
though and here's the other one from Sly
uh more news the gentleman we have been
seeing in the trailer with Sebastian's
Uncle so there was that bit of news
and then Chandler
so this is all happening December 3rd
Chandler posts music video in 4k coming
Monday
it's Tuesday guys we already have the
music video
oh yeah if any of you play fortnite make
sure to use uh Creator code racketour we
got that set up a few months back
raconteur in the Epic item shop and then
then they revealed it yesterday this is
the music of your legacy we're gonna get
into a full breakdown here in a second
uh then
in addition to that
they also Eric Martin marketing manager
at uh Avalanche WB had some behind the
scenes if you don't follow Eric on
Twitter
how many ease we got in there Eric one
two three four e r e e e k
on Twitter he had a couple behind the
scenes uh that he shared here's a
picture so they filmed this on location
uh at Avalanche in in Utah from what I
understand that was what the YouTube
description said so he had some fun
little behind the scenes shots here that
I thought were great we're gonna get
into the music video here in a second
and break it all down but Eric directed
this whole thing guys so make sure you
uh give him give him props man give him
a shout out
I actually I'm marketing like my
full-time work I'm a marketing manager
as well not in not in the gaming
industry but
I feel like Eric you know Chandler is
kind of the front facing
Chandler's the one who gets gets a lot
of the praise from fans and also a lot
of the the uh disgruntledness from fans
but then Eric's a little bit more behind
the scenes but also has been incredibly
hard at work doing some amazing things
so there was this one and then this one
right here he shared as well
I mean look at that setup man I'd love
to know like the tech nerd in me I would
love to know about like this projector
setup
like how were they projecting it onto
this curved
screen here
or maybe they had like two oh that's
just it's so cool man so cool
so let's see did he post any others no
okay that was that was all the behind
the scenes from him
and then a random fantasy football post
from me
okay then today
this one I'm gonna watch with you guys
and react live
gonna react live to this one because I
have not watched this one in detail yet
volte what is up my friend with the 4.99
Super Chat I'm here now what's popping
also thought the music video was awesome
to be honest I've listened to it like 12
times out it's so good right
right by the way chat did Shadow got it
I'm so sorry eight minutes ago I think I
missed Shadow guided Super Chat
I'm so sorry guys like I just like
you're just seeing my excitement man
shadow guy I'm so sorry the channel
quickly entered my top three favorite I
don't know if you're talking about me or
Hogwarts Legacy Shadow guided but either
way thank you so much for the super chat
if I'm in your top three
that is very much appreciated but if
you've been Hogwarts Legacy I understand
that too I understand that too Shadow
guided thank you so much volte thank you
so much per barthol with a super chat as
well which I don't see a comment with
that one so thank you so much for
showing the support I don't know if you
had uh it was about me shout out oh nice
thank you Shadow guided thank you very
much
and then Elwyn jumping it with a super
chat as well I literally shed some tears
when I heard the music for the first
time especially the middle triumphant
feeling part I love what music can do
it's incredible and I I
how do I describe this like I am not a
big
I don't know a lot about the
technicality of music
I guess that would be a good way to put
it in uh in college I took
how many classes did I take on I had one
classical music class that I just I
didn't think I was gonna like this class
at all and it was one of my favorite
classes I loved it loved it
we had to go to like that we were
required to go to this concert on campus
and it was just it was phenomenal like
hearing this stuff live there really is
man like even though I'm not technically
like I can't describe to you in in my
video breakdown which I posted today
guys if you haven't seen it
um
this one right here
actually let me go to the channel let me
go uh let me just hit this right here
so this one right here the one with the
wow thumbnail
volte with another Super Chat yes volte
we've got another video that they
dropped today
that's kind of like a behind the scenes
on the uh
on the music which we're gonna watch
here here in just a moment together
Elwyn with another Super Chat also loved
how they made the conductors baton look
like it was casting I didn't even pick
up on that at first elwin I missed that
until I was uh somebody commented that
somebody in my comments on so this video
right here is my reaction to it guys
if you haven't seen that yet check it
out
but um how did I get on this point oh
yeah I was saying like I don't
understand the technical piece of music
that's I'm not your guy for that
but in terms of like what the music
makes you feel
I could talk about that I could talk
about the emotions and there's just
something it's something special about
music man right that can transcend can
transcend language can transcend time I
mean how long has Classical classical
music
the the oldest piece of classical music
you can find
still to this day it can evoke emotions
and move people I just thought they
absolutely knocked it out of the park I
may I think I make that clear in this
video
um he's a wizard right
so
yeah
I was I was blown away by it and then
today
they now posted
okay this is this is the original one
and then here's this one
so I'm gonna pull this up and then we're
gonna I'm gonna get caught up on
actually I'm gonna let it play right now
with no music and then I'm gonna get
caught up on the comments and then we
will uh watch this together and kind of
break it down
okay so let me make sure I got all the
super chats we had Elwyn times two we
had volte times two we had per barthol
and then we had Shadow guided nice we
got all of you
and then I also looked like we had a
couple new subscribers to the channel as
well so welcome to the new subscribers
thank you all
Caroline says as a music Major not
knowing the technical portions is
mentally healing
yeah it's just amazing to me that
there's
that they're able I said this before I
even saw Chandler's post about it
because he said that it's something
nostalgic yet also familiar
that's that's like exactly
how I felt
it's like oh this sounds I'm in wait
where am I oh my god oh this is this is
the Wizarding World
Oh wait we're getting hedwigs no no wait
no it's not hedwig's theme no no it's
something different but it's very close
oh I like this it's it's crazy
crazy and awesome AJ draws what is up my
friend with a super chat as well hello
retro and all you other beautiful
witches Wizards I love how the
soundtrack captured the magic of the
first film Mystery of the second and
looming darkness of the ladder
AJ 100 agree did they not like they hit
every note
no pun intended nobody did they I mean
they just hit they hit all the right
notes guys they really did and I know
it's I know I'm heaping lots of Praise
right now you guys know on this channel
like I try to keep it real with you guys
if they if I don't like the way things
are looking or if I've got concerns
about something I'll Tell You music for
a while is something that a lot of
people were wondering about you know
because I know the first trailer
a lot of people were like oh I don't
know if I love this this bombastic you
know
this this bit really big I felt very big
that first trailer I liked it but but a
lot of people were a little concerned
like okay do they realize here
I mean when when the series starts off
hiring a guy like John Williams right
what do you do the first I think he did
the first three movies I think John
Williams did the first three
just a legend right and then you have
Jeremy Soule who is a legend in the
video game industry doing the video
games
there are so many iconic sounds of the
Wizarding World
and they clearly knew how important that
was they clearly knew
so it's just so exciting to see
and I have I I literally have nothing I
have no complaints I have no well but on
any of this stuff like as far as the
music goes this is a medley so they you
know we heard different sections
of what's going to be in the game
I mean and you can almost place like
that's what I was trying to do when I
went back
and did my videos like okay let me try
and figure out where would this be
what's gonna be happening at the game in
the game when we hear this playing and
some of them you can already I think you
can already make a pretty good guess
cake in a retro wreck into her stream on
your birthday is the best fandom draws
happy birthday
enjoy your cake
oh is Casey not feeling well
agree with Elle when Casey hope you feel
better soon always say that I don't have
to agree with the artist on everything
to appreciate the art yeah yeah yeah
sorry just double checking to make sure
I uh
see if I missed any any important
comments can we get a like Spike from
the chat Dr Robo Panda yeah that's right
guys uh make sure to like the Stream
helps other people find it and if we get
100
we get to 100 likes which I have no idea
what we're at now but if we get to 100
we will do a random Harry Potter quote
quiz first week we did one that was
fairly easy last week we did one that
was pretty hard
so this week we might have to try to go
go with something in the middle
76 all right 76 and Counting let's go
all right so let's let's watch this
together
like I said I watched this very briefly
while at work but I didn't really have
time to fully process it and break it
down 94 okay hold on let me wait let me
wait let me wait
we might want to just go ahead and do
the
might want to go ahead and do the quote
I'll just play this again
there we go yeah
all right thank you guys thank you guys
all right so let's let's go here I'm
gonna see I gotta pull from a different
spot this time because the last website
foreign
was not that good
and I'll be honest with you guys the
last one that we were pulling from like
all of them were
they kept pulling from Dumbledore most
of them were Dumbledore or
um Sirius which they have some of the
most
iconic lines you know
oh that one's too easy
that one's too easy
oh this might be a good one
oh but it doesn't tell me which book
oh come on
okay yeah there there's the book all
right all right all right got it got it
got it
okay let me mute the music oh oh wait
wait wait right before that the ore
division
the aura division what is up my friend
with a 4.99 Super Chat we were just
talking about you or division we were
going through some of your tweets thank
you so much for your uh translation help
and uh getting that news out to everyone
from the Brazil event that was uh that
was big time my friend came in clutch
very clutch or division says retro loved
your wow I know right though wow on the
thumbnail as a violinist myself got very
emotional amazing Overture they captured
both the Whimsical terrify notes
perfectly yes yes like I was telling
them earlier that
I just like I'm not a you're a violinist
so you probably understand all the
technical what's happening when which
instruments you're hearing that's not me
at all but I was like I still want to
make a video like this because I I can't
talk about the emotions I can talk about
what this is making me feel I can talk
about where I could see this fitting
at various points of the game but yeah
man it's just it was so good it was so
good and I told I just told chat like I
know it sounds like I try to keep it
real with you guys you know when I think
there's something that needs to be
critiqued if there are things that I
have concerns about you know I'll tell
you
this I mean they they took the pitch and
they just crushed this for a baseball
analogy I mean they knocked it out of
the park knocked it out of the park
I have zero complaints we're getting
ready to dive into the uh the video here
where they uh like the behind the scenes
making the music so thank you so much
for your Super Chat and and again for
your support on the ground there getting
us that news uh Casey with a super chat
have a US
wait hold on let me see I don't know if
you wanted me to read this out loud
oh my goodness
I'm assuming you're okay with it being
read out loud it's since it was a super
chat
um Casey says CT scan this Thursday from
a moped wreck I was in back in June oh
my goodness scared but hope things will
be okay guys get some love for Casey in
the chat hope everything goes well with
that man I can definitely
see why that would be a little
nerve-wracking all the way back in June
that it's crazy how some of those like
injuries like that can really linger
hoping for the best Casey hoping for the
best
okay well I I think I had found
oh yeah and that's why I muted the music
because I had found a quote okay so we
hit 100 likes whenever we hit 100 likes
guys we do a random quote from the Harry
Potter series and see if you all can
guess it you get one point
in the imaginary point total that gets
nothing really you get one point if you
get the character right you get two
points if you can get the right book so
respond with the character and then book
okay so this one's kind of short
and then there's there's one kind of
byprocess of elimination you can rule
someone out okay here's the quote
Dumbledore says people find it far
easier to forgive others for being wrong
than being right
one more time here
the quote
Dumbledore says people find it far
easier to forgive others for being wrong
than being right
all right I'll play them I'll turn the
music back on give you guys a second
let me take a look at the chat here
see if anyone is getting it right
all right we got Dobby book one we got
Hermione book six we got Hermione
question mark Hermione book five
Hermione Half Blood Prince
lots of Hermione's feather says Percy
Jordan says Loop in book five
uh wow I don't remember this at all yeah
we're going I mean we're just pulling
like
we had a super easy one week one last
week's was a little bit harder
serious book five like Sirius and
Dumbledore are always good guesses
because there's so many quotes for them
but uh that people like use often but
obviously we know we can rule out
Dumbledore since he's in this one
Hermione book three Hermione haploid
Prince
uh Voldemort in book three Taylor says
Nico Hermione book six
Hermione no Lupine in book six I think
zodiac I know it's referring to Percy
feathers Percy doesn't say it it's just
about him don't remember who said it
Alicia me and book two it's a moment to
remember which number haploid Prince was
Hermione book six
all right all right all right so
uh somebody was saying repeated again
yeah so it's Dumbledore says people find
it far easier to forgive others for
being wrong
than being right
and a couple of you got this one right
it is Hermione and it was also from
Harry Potter and the Half Blood Prince
book six and I do think you guys are
right as well it doesn't say on on this
but I I'm pretty sure you guys are right
that it was relating to Percy
because it was um she was talking to Ron
when she said it
all right that's fun I like that new
addition to the streams if you guys are
just jumping in we do that whenever we
hit 100 likes in the Stream now I need
to come up with something for 200 likes
oh that one needs to be like more
I don't know like um
I don't know it's got to be like
slightly embarrassing to me I feel like
because that's what you know chat always
loves when
the streamers are embarrassing
themselves
two points for zodiac
for 200 it's your Dolores umber Dolores
umberjee oh my gosh that would
I don't know if I've ever done a Dolores
umbrage impression
that'd be a tough one I'd have to
practice that one I'd need to practice
that one
all right CJ welcome what have I missed
a lot
I never know what to say when people
when people come in and ask that
um I mean you've not missed too much but
definitely go back and replay the
beginning that's the thing I love about
YouTube
I usually never catch the beginning of
James's uh Wizarding Wednesday but I can
just go back to the beginning I'll like
put it at 2x speed and then get caught
up before he ends
so yeah it makes it really easy to jump
back or you guys can always watch the
next day we keep the VOD up on the
channel
which we talked about this last time
YouTube kind of
where the live stream show up if you go
to my main page it does not show up like
on the video page unless you scroll down
and look at my little uh have like a
playlist for it but then there's another
whole section just for live stream so
you can see all of them there
all right so we are getting ready to
watch together here guys Hogwarts Legacy
making the music so I'm gonna go ahead
and turn off the music here in Spotify
and then we're gonna watch this so this
is a brand new one so this came out
today you guys and it is about the big
music video that we already uh I mean
things are happening so fast now I've
already made a video on this but we
haven't talked about it much on the live
stream yet so let's take a listen here
so starting off the same
[Music]
it's glad to see a Gryffindor
we don't have a Gryffindor Professor yet
you know after all the things I've
worked on this this represents the
Pinnacle so there you go lead composer
right there
oh Chuck E Myers is just the most
amazing project and the most amazing
team of people I can't believe all the
incredible people that are making this
whole Vision come to life every time I
play a video game The Sound uh enhances
the experience so much and yep I was so
glad to be a part of the audio team at
Avalanche because it really does enhance
that experience and makes such a great
memorable thing for the players this job
of writing music for something just
lists the whole thing it's already a
good game but the music I think so that
when he said that it's already a good
game so I'm like did all of them get to
did they get to play
have they played the whole game do they
play certain sections of the game exit
to another level makes it fantastic
[Music]
we wanted to make Hogwarts Legacy our
own that little bit right there I feel
like Zelda The Hobbit vibes from it we
wanted to put our own stamp and our own
brand on it you can hear it in the music
not only does it sound new and fresh
it's nostalgic yeah
[Music]
you know I wanted to hearken back to
like Nostalgia factors I love this part
right here I love this I feel like
today's game scores is a lot of texture
based kind of scores I have no idea what
he means by texture-based scores and so
I want to bring back the you know heroic
kind of fanfares of trumpets or you know
melodic elements you know with the
violence and kind of bring back the
Magic in the childlike on wonder
it's when they talk about the part I
felt like is that the Brilliance of John
Williams's head this this part he's
talking about hedwig's theme and and uh
Noob with a super chat what is up Noob
welcome my friend just a friendly
reminder to stay hydrated and healthy
Noob thank you so much for the Super
Chat the support we've got a uh peach
Waterloo
tonight
this is this is like this might be my
favorite line I'm going to rewind it
just a bit so we can hear it all the way
through
the one thing we felt like is that the
Brilliance of John Williams is hedwig's
theme he hadn't even seen the movie and
he wrote that incredible piece of music
where the Celeste and the violins is so
brilliant and it just sounds like magic
yes I suppose the biggest I I said that
even before
the video that I put up today I hadn't
even heard him say that yet when I
recorded that I mean that's exactly it's
almost like you feel like oh wait
they're about to go into hedwig's theme
but wait no no this is something
different this is slightly different
I suppose the biggest factor for the
scores was trying to help it fit in with
the other music that we have for the
Harry Potter films we were so important
idea that what if there was an older
Melody of lore that might have been an
earlier this part version of hedwigs and
so the ancient magic Melody kind of grew
out of that idea to say what if it could
be a relative of hedwig's theme you just
hear a little bit of something
recognizable and I think that just makes
the experience a bit more fun and I
think it's a perfect fit it fits really
well
the ancient so did you guys catch that
they call that the ancient magic theme
let's listen to that part again what if
the ancient magic or films we were
thinking about the idea that what if
there was an older Melody of this I love
this it's been an earlier version of
hedwig's and so the ancient magic Melody
kind of grew out of that idea to say
what if it could be a relative of
hedwig's theme you just hear a little
bit of something recognizable
um and I think that that just makes the
experience a bit more fun and I think
it's a perfect fit it fits really well
foreign
is too low you guys can't hear that at
all
my gosh it's like I just turned it up
it's like blasting in my ear hold on let
me try this
I'm going to turn it up in a different
spot I just I have to remember to turn
it down later or you guys will get uh
blasted
so sanguine Tails textured is more about
tone Timber and synthesis okay
interesting
video volume a bit low
wait what did uh AJ draw said they're
using cellos and violins to reflect the
time those instruments were very popular
in the 19th century nice
I can hear it LOL volume is good okay
all right
so I'm gonna put this in the middle and
I'm gonna turn it up a bit over here
and then we'll listen to this part again
available and I think that that just
makes the experience a bit more fun and
I think it's a perfect fit and I really
hold on that might have been thinking
about the idea that what if there was an
older Melody of lore that might have
been an earlier version of hedwig's and
so the ancient magic Melody kind of grew
out of that idea to say what if it could
be a relative of hedwig's theme you just
hear a little bit of something
recognizable and I think that that just
makes the experience a bit more fun and
I think it's a perfect fit it fits
really well
I'm so glad that I the video I posted
today I'm so glad I recorded that before
they posted this because if I had people
be like you didn't you you just took
what they said so I guess it's a good
sign to them I I picked up on I was able
to pick up on all these things even
being somebody not familiar with music
just somebody who's loved the Harry
Potter World loved the music of Harry
Potter
I was able to pick up on almost all
these things now the part about the
ancient magic stuff and thinking
thinking of it as a previous version of
hedwig's theme like an earlier one from
lore is just just brilliant just
absolutely brilliant
it can be kind of tricky to know what to
write to know what notes to play some of
these darker moments they they're
balanced with some real beautiful darker
moments so the music does go through
quite a shift it it goes from big
powerful Combat music
that in the background right there
oh I was gonna see is there a clue back
here somewhere
to very slow very emotional strings
not every moment in the game has music
not every moment and every film has
music but when you need it it makes all
the difference
that part right there man
I have to say wait is that Chandler up
there this is the most challenging thing
I've ever
foreign
thing I've ever been involved with just
because of where you know the music has
been going where there's so many
variations and options and things that
we're exploring and the creative
Direction on this we have to account for
every single action that the player can
do while music is playing so for example
if you're out in the Overland and you
want to mount or fly you have to
consider that the player can do that
within a mission or they might start a
mission or they might enter a cavern or
they might enter a building or a shop
and music we want to be dynamic and
change through all those different
experiences see I love how it's like if
you don't if you don't watch it all the
way through you don't get a look at the
new stuff this is and we had to account
at start all right let's go back while
music is okay so this part right here
I think what this means is that so
you're running around and then as soon
as you jump onto the broom you're gonna
get different music is is what I'm
getting from this let's listen to him
again here Direction on this we have to
account for every single action that the
player can do while music is playing so
for example if you're out in the
Overland and you want to mount or fly we
have to consider that the player can do
that within a mission or they might
start a mission or they might enter a
cavern or they might enter
little decorations over here
looks like for like the fall decorations
right there too across the top
which we've seen Hogs me before uh and
then you got quality quidditch supplies
over here zonkos for a building or a
shop and then our first look inside the
three Broomsticks
and
music
want to be dynamic and change through
all those different experiences and we
had to account for all that and every
single thing that the player could
possibly do in the game you got to
transition all these scores and
hopefully they all kind of blend
together right and so that's a really
difficult part as opposed to linear film
you know linear storytelling it's like
you have to put in a lot of it's a good
point to make that magic and the ancient
magic theme and all those themes really
match the whole feeling of these
different moments in the game that's
been you know just such a collaborative
effort we had to make every area in
psycho with a super chat have they
confirmed the ability to jump
well thank you so much for the Super
Chat
no and yes
we're gonna go back we're gonna go back
to that spot right there and we're gonna
go to a tweet that Chandler posted as
well
we're gonna because I I mean clearly we
just saw you can jump right the question
is is there a dedicated jump button to
where you can just like you know freely
jump at any point in the game or is it
more of a contextual nature so you run
to the ledge you Auto jump off
even if you push a button you know maybe
you push a button at the ledge and you
jump off similar to what you you've seen
in the more recent God of War games and
the old school Zelda games uh not breath
of the wild because they did add a
dedicated jump button for that one but
in like Ocarina of Time Majora's Mask
like you you couldn't jump but if you
ran ran off a ledge link would jump if
you ran up to the edge and needed to
climb up link would automatically jump
so that's the question and then I saw a
comment from somebody was saying yeah I
don't think I don't think anything here
diagonally confirm I mean Gringotts
probably confirmed yes
but how we get there
I'm still thinking we're going to get
there through those portals from in that
area with fig I don't know that we're
actually going to go to Diagon Alley and
go in the traditional way but who knows
who knows
maybe we will
uh let's see what else there was another
comment I saw that I wanted to
respond to I think it was AJ
where did it go AJ I'm so sorry oh there
it is retro the challenge of the music
might be the transition from one
soundtrack to the yeah yeah yeah he
literally just addressed it right
Carlos what's up Carlos thank you so
much Carlos always here showing love and
support to the stream uh Super Chat
coming in there when you heard the
Hogwarts sexy theme did you cry I did
not cry of happiness but I definitely
got chills definitely got chills so good
my friend
so good interesting and there are places
all right let's rewind a bit just a week
no linear storytelling it's like you
have to put in a lot of different music
to make that magic and the ancient magic
theme and all those themes really match
the whole feeling of these different
moments in the game that's been you know
just such a collaborative effort we have
to make every area interesting and there
are places like the herbology area or
the common rooms that we have custom
music for just to make that exploration
and that kind of Newfound area more
special and more important to the player
yeah we've heard all the common room
music which is also amazing
[Music]
writing all the different common rooms
you had to infuse all the different
characteristics of each one of those and
I studied up on all those different
houses and how do you make that Infuse
that into a score we've tried a lot of
unique things that we've never tried
before in anything else that we've
worked on one instrument that we were
looking for a giant this is crazy right
here Thunder sheet and so you'll hear in
the ancient magic theme that you'll hear
the thunder sheets coming into almost
like waves of emotion coming in true
story my grandpa
he ran his own uh heating and air
business
and I remember being in his shop so many
times and they had these these giant
pieces of sheet metal
and I remember like doing not not like
this but I remember like taking my hand
and like pushing on those and creating a
very similar sound this is what I love
about like musicians like just like what
can we do to make this sound sheet metal
that's it the Thunder sheets coming into
almost like waves of emotion coming in
foreign
and then that combined with another
really unique instrument called the
water phone it just makes these sounds
you see using a sucker on that I didn't
want to say anything because I didn't
want to look look stupid there
because I I was I was thinking uh it
looked it looks kind of like a sucker
but it's probably not
musical people tell us what what is what
is this device right here
what is this thing here
and then that combined with another
unique instrument called the water phone
it just makes these sounds that
literally sound like magic
I don't know if I'm mad I'm feeling more
I don't care so much about the music red
and the time that we spent on each
individual little granular part of the
mission and each score that is
associated with it kind of speaks for
itself every note every chord
progression every chord every harmonic
structure everything I pour so much into
that it takes the best elements from the
films and it adds something new and so
it'll be familiar and feel like it fits
and is at home in the Harry Potter World
I love the team that I'm working with I
love this project I'm so proud of what
everyone's done and and like to me like
last night some of the people we were
talking about with the orchestra we had
the orchestra over at the studio and I
had com wait is this a UK you guys don't
call these suckers lollipop yeah yeah
lollipop there you go
probably a mallet says JP raven fire
what's a sucker that's let's call it the
UK Mallet okay I see a couple people
saying mallet
gotcha comments saying like you know
this was probably one of the greatest
moments in my life you know working
through these scores and getting
together as a team just the spirit of
everyone there together thank you so
much and thank you to the fans really
because without the fans this wouldn't
you're welcome you're welcome glad we
could be a part of this too even be
possible I just feel so lucky thank you
to everyone who's made this happen
nah seriously a minute thank you to
these guys right I mean just
amazing amazing amazing
oh goodness okay
all right I do want to go back I do want
to go back and we gotta talk now so now
let's shift gears a bit
and let's talk about like the new like
game stuff like right here right here
right here right here
but we had a comment from hallberry
there how long until you think the game
has gone gold I imagine it'll be soon
given the holiday break and then review
copies being three to four weeks after
that
I would guess yeah I would I would say
mid early early to mid-January yeah so
we're probably about a month out from it
going gold
that's just it's amazing amazing psycho
with another Super Chat there deployed
right now have to wait until March to
play oh dude well thank you for your
service first of all very much
appreciate your service
and then
you have to wait till March ah that I
mean that's not too bad right are you
able to play like I'm not sure what uh
like where exactly you're located do you
do you have like down time where you
where you all can play games
or none of that where you're at they're
all law they're all lollies
prisoner basketball yeah so somebody was
asking about the old school Harry Potter
games yeah you you did not
uh you didn't jump in those
the fur in the first ones that oh wait
no you did you did you could jump in
you could jump on the PC version for
sure
you jump on the PC version for sure
but now I can't remember about like
Chamber of Secrets and Prisoner of
Azkaban even though I just played them
some reason I don't think you can with
those somebody in chat will correct me
now folks we aren't jumping I know right
Chris I I think Chandler is taking uh
PS1 Philosopher's Stone had no specific
jumping only contextual okay yeah well
the PC one so maybe you're talking about
the console one
wait could you not
could you not jump into PC
I'm almost positive you can jump in the
PC one
or maybe you guys are right maybe it's
only at Ledges and I'm just totally
misremembering
but yeah I think Chandler's having good
fun with uh all the questions about
jumping which is why he won't just come
out and answer it
realistically guys
I'll just be honest with you there are
some people who care a lot about this
you can't jump a PC but only across gaps
Professor Baxter I was totally
misremembered I was picturing the gaps
but yeah I didn't remember that you
can't just like jump in place
so
the jumping question let me first show
you all Chandler's comment
let me show you Chandler's comment
let's see
which by the way Joe
Mack everybody on Twitter if you can't
make a the alignment chart from your
comedian manager do you even have one
this is fit uh Finch Strife that says uh
Chandler's Twitter
it's his one year anniversary with
Avalanche guys
and this cracked me up from Joe I love
that
but um right here right here right here
so I posted I posted this tweet
which was from uh oh deep here on
Twitter they they just clipped out those
scenes that we were talking about there
the new stuff that we saw in that
trailer we just watched
couple of new Hogwarts Legacy Clips so
then someone took mine and replied or no
Hogwarts Legacy news quote tweeted me
and said that jump off the ledge on the
Broom was Magnifique Bravo Avalanche
super travail travail you're a wizard
Harry and then Chandler says did someone
say jump
and he puts it in quotes and he's got
the smelly face
and then look I tried you guys I tried
I tried to get more out of him
he wasn't biting I said so can we
confirm a dedicated jump button or is it
more of an auto ledge type jump like in
the new God of War games
totally clear with all of you guys I
personally do not care
I have enjoyed games immensely with no
jump button I've enjoyed games immensely
that have a jump button personally I
don't feel like Hogwarts Legacy needs
one because of the type of action
I don't think it needs like a dedicated
you can just
so people saying why wouldn't it well
it's just like it's just not necessary
it's just not necessary there's not
going to be any platforming where it
would be necessary if that were the case
right
so the reason so many people are now
speculating on this
is because we just saw this shot right
here
coming up right here
okay I'm gonna put it in slow motion
here
and so our character very clearly jumps
they jump off the ledge and then just
out of nowhere some in the broom
which
love this animation by the way
love this animation there you get the
jump
and then
it just appears I wonder if we if they
like audibly say accio or something
oh dude they might there's like this
little there's like this little trail of
gold
right and okay no I don't know what the
little trail of gold maybe that's just
like showing you taking off or something
uh
so I mean clearly you can jump in the
game but now my question is is it only a
contextual jump
so contextual guys what that means is
that just like what we were talking
about with with the PC version of the
old school games like you could only
jump at the ledge
so like you get to a ledge there's a gap
you have to LEAP across and you can jump
there or you get to an area where you
have to climb up you climb up there if
you've played the recent God of War
games so 2018 or Ragnarok exactly like
that
if you play the old school like um
oh geez bloodborne and Dark Souls demon
souls like those do not have jump
buttons then Elden ring they added a
dedicated jump button where you can jump
anytime
another good example the old school
Zelda game so Ocarina of Time Majora's
Matt 3D Zelda games Ocarina of Time
Majora's Mask those did not have a
dedicated jump button it was it was
contextual so you don't see them
all the time in like action-adventory
type games just because there's not
enough platforming to justify it
so that is where this big question comes
from
and so we clearly see there's going to
be some sort of jumping mechanic but I
still don't think this ultimately
answers the question that everybody
wants to know
I don't think it answers the question
everybody wants to know
it's Mr Mo great question right there
what button would you put it on because
personally like X being Dodge roll
so that's the other thing we don't know
enough about the control scheme
we know that for spells you hold R2
and that is what when you're holding R2
then all of the face buttons x square
circle triangle become spell buttons
so you definitely if x is Jump which it
traditionally is then you couldn't jump
right there when you're doing that
but oh here's another thing I just
thought of we know that you can when
you're in combat when you're locked on
you can definitely roll so there's
definitely like a kind of a roll evade
mechanic
retro should ask Chandler for an
interview uh I doubt Chandler has time
for an interview right now I asked him
long long ago when he first started
doing the uh
when he first started doing his role as
Community manager I said hey
love to have you on
on the channel on a live stream video
Whatever anytime
and he he he didn't say no
but he didn't say yes either obviously
but I mean I'd love to have him on at
some point
he's probably he's probably pretty busy
though right now I would say
probably pretty busy and let's be honest
if we had him on here
he couldn't answer a fraction of what we
would want to know just because I mean
they're not going to reveal everything
they are not gonna reveal everything
so what do you guys think dedicated jump
button or no
all right hold on let me see I actually
you know what I'll put a new poet for
that so last poll we had up was Will
Hogwarts Legacy show anything new at the
game awards 81 percent said yes 19 said
no which by the way guys I am about 90
sure that I will be co-streaming the
event live
I know two retro streams in the same
week pretty crazy right
so unless I think the only way I
wouldn't stream is if we got some
definitive
if Chandler came out beforehand and said
we're definitely not there's not going
to be anything new then I probably
wouldn't
but if there's a chance and I think
there is a chance that we could see
something new
and we know where they're definitely
gonna have they're going to be up for
the most anticipated Awards so
all right I'm gonna go ahead and end
that poll
and then we're going to make a new poll
here
we're going to make a new Pole
and here's the question will Hogwarts
Legacy have a dedicated
jump button question mark yes or no
though yes or no
oh no not add option whoops
ask your community
all right there it is there it is
vote let me know what you think I I'm
thinking no I I really don't think
there's a dedicated jump button I feel
like it's contextual I feel like it's
going to be like God of War
137 likes
and lowercase Logan what is up my friend
I think it'll be at TGA literally every
time we think oh they won't show
anything new at this event they show
something new and a lot of times usually
they're pretty good about telling us
beforehand like we knew the Brazil thing
was gonna happen we just didn't know how
much
Alicia can have an option for I don't
know but I'll be sad if there isn't one
well no you can't
sorry Alicia
this is a prediction you gotta you gotta
go one way or another what do you
predict yes or no
Professor Baxter think it'll be
contextual would love to be surprised
that's kind of where I'm at yeah
drummer boy retro been a while hope
you're doing good hey thank you for
stopping by
don't think jumping is needed that's
kind of where I'm at I mean I don't I
haven't seen anything gameplay wise that
would lead me to think that it would be
needed
you're not going to be jumping around
while you're while you're dueling and
doing battle
you're going to be you know doing the
role and the the Dodge the evade the
protego that we've seen that's what
you're going to be doing
oh and I think we know try we know
triangles not jump triangle is protego
you're a wizard Harry and by the way for
any of you worried about like what
buttons do what I wouldn't worry about
that because I would guess they'll have
in-game accessibility options to change
all of that but even if they don't I
know for sure PS5 has where you can
completely remap the entire controller
do whatever you want so you can put the
buttons on anything
but um and I'm pretty sure Xbox does the
same thing as well
it's Mr
chat as well Mr Mo thank you for the
Port I feel like
to have a dedicated jump button hoping
we can customize button layout though
sort of where I'm at yeah there's
there's a lot of controls in this game
like look at that lollipop dude that's
totally a lollipop
Chandler can we get confirmation is that
a uh was that was that a lollipop
he's smiling too over there almost
almost like yo we got this uh lollipop
here let's see if that will work
now that like yeah something more
musical right there
but the lollipop
oh it is really this this pole is
insanely close right now right now we've
got 99 people who have voted if you
haven't voted yet get your vote in there
oh it just locked up completely we had a
we're at a hundred votes 50 say yes
dedicated jump button 50 say no
dedicated Jumpman wow split right down
the middle
are you kidding me
that is not a lollipop
Dr Sherman
come on now it's totally a lollipop
don't burst our bubble here
do not burst our bubble it's a it's a
lollipop
look oh come on
come on
lollipop right there
oh I know it's not a lollipop
I know it's not a lollipop
come on Dr sherbet it's not like we get
anything wrong here you know better than
that
no in all seriousness I I did know it
wasn't a lollipop but it totally looks
like a lollipop
totally looks like a lollipop
far too big dude I remember at school
maybe this is only a us thing they used
to do for like these special fundraisers
maybe anyone in the US who remembers
this they would do these little
fundraisers people would sell suckers
and they were like the I mean they look
just like that but they were different
colors but it was just like completely
spherical
lollipop
they were pretty big
what if Chandler hops in and goes LOL oh
wait it just disappeared on me
no what if Chandler Hopson and goes LOL
that totally is one guy
like yes I know there's a lot of
questions people have about the game
Chandler but come on can we just get
confirmation is it a lollipop or not
Dr Sherwood I'm an evil Hufflepuff
anyone remember yeah AJ exactly those
jawbreakers were huge they were huge
and then we also had uh like if you go
to like carnivals
trying to think like fairs state fairs
county fairs like those giant
circular
suckers but they're like flat
so the other ones I was talking about
they're more spherical in shape but then
they have those that are flat I mean
they're they're huge they get to be the
size of your head just about
or division broke a tooth because of one
oh goodness
what's this about a live off Timothy
ninja well I mean we were just
commenting here on how I mean look
they're they're using lollipops in the
uh to make the music of Hogwarts Legacy
I think that's pretty cool
I think it's pretty cool
you guys are saying way too big I mean
no that's not too big for a lollipop
look look at that in relation to his
head here that could 100 be a lollipop
they're like what do we have around here
you guys oh wait wait there there it is
again oh this might this might
officially debunk the lollipop Theory I
don't think they would just lay it down
on the on the leather chair like that
just be too sticky you know
just be a little too sticky on the chair
Tootsie Roll Pop
oh my gosh man
but okay so we got off track there we
got off track So for anybody who jumped
in is wondering uh the poll question
right now is there a dedicated jump
button
I know Chandler just loves that we're
debating the jump button because I feel
like in the grand scheme of things it
really doesn't mean a whole lot
also got another scene here which Nico
pointed out to me Noob with another
Super Chat retro you should definitely
apologize for ruining Alicia's Dream of
jumping in duels definitely not doing
this to get back all those house points
I lost did you lose house points noob
how did you lose house points
what did you do
can't we get a poll about if it's uh
alive
Dustin it's a lie it's a lollipop
oh my goodness thank you all for the
super chats
did I miss Mr Moe oh no wait Mr Moe oh
yeah I read Mr Mose
so we also got this shot Nico pointed
out to me
wait a second oh dude Nico it's
different in this one
Okay this may mean nothing of
significance at all you guys but
so in this video right here look at that
so that's our character just as we've
seen before in the shot where they're in
Gringotts with fig with the Goblin
and our character is wearing what we
think is the attire at the beginning of
the game
character building with Alicia
foreign
thank you for the support though
appreciate it
Noob and Alicia best Pals you guys best
Pals
our very own let's see if we had to if
we had to compare them to two
like Harry Potter characters
oh who would who would be like a good a
good Duo of Harry Potter characters
they're kind of like
I mean are they like our Fred and George
here
it's like a Fred and George pairing
Dr Sherwood I missed this AJ I pushed
quite a few
sticky suckers and girls hair in Primary
School oh my gosh middle school as you
called in the U.S
not character building it's bullying
peeves and filch oh dude I didn't say it
Timothy ninja said it I mean I guess
technically I did say it I repeated it
but
it originated with you Timothy
originate with you okay hold on though
we gotta talk about this that
um Nico pointed out to me so in this one
they're wearing the normal attire but
then check out
let's see uh Hogwarts Legacy music
probably we'll get it to come up
there it is
oh and where's the time stamp on it
let's see so in this
trailer
foreign
they also show a shot here it is right
here oh oh my goodness
[Music]
and here our character oh it was really
quick too the character is 100 wearing
robes
100 wearing robes
so Nico and I were kind of speculating
what does this mean does this mean that
we were wrong about when that first trip
takes place
because we saw the attire and thought oh
they're going into the beginning of the
game that's possibility
I threw out it could also mean that we
can go back and forth to Gringotts maybe
we go more than once
maybe it's something we can freely go to
and of course we know we can change out
our attire but seeing this right here
and again keep in mind guys like
trailers people that follow movie
trailers a lot know this like all of the
this could change
like this may not be 100 accurate this
may never actually happen this exact
shot as we're seeing it now may never
actually happen in the game
but
does this mean that
we definitely can at some point go to
Gringotts after
getting our school ropes
I think yes if we can take this at face
value here which I'm I'm kind of I'm
kind of arguing it both ways here like
I'm saying we can't take it at face
value but if we could
that's definitely School robes there
though and then again just for
comparison in the other one right here
that's definitely like the previous one
where they're in the uh
pre-hogwarts attire
hey have a good one fandom draws thank
you for being here maybe there are
multiple Goblin locations that use those
carts
okay yeah let's compare the
let me move this over here
it does I mean we only see this one for
such a short time
it does look
I mean it does look like a different
spot but I think both of them are
100 gringots
and fig is with us both times
he's with us both times
oh I've been to the bank once when I
first set up my account
oh my goodness ran Rock in the chat
it's School robes and a different main
character altogether yeah it's it's
absolutely a different character ran
rock yeah it's a different main
character
I see I think a lot of us before
we were piecing all of this together
because we see
the main character
and fig in Gringotts the main character
we see this in the cut scene in this in
the trailer the main character in that
full I'm just calling it pre-hogwarts
attire because I don't know what else to
call it
and we that's when fig has his little
interaction with ran Rock and then we
also had this shot right here and so a
lot of us were trying to piece that
together and say okay this must happen
before we get to Hogwarts Vegas kind of
acting as our Hagrid helping us get set
up in the Wizarding World all of that
but now
seeing this
which by the way this was only a quick
second but this one shows up much
clearer do I not have this one at 4K
yeah I do
this one shows up much much clearer
maybe you can play as multiple
characters or it's hinting at a
character creator system
well there's definitely a character
creator system we've seen that
but I don't think it's any I don't think
it's like multiple characters I'm just
talking more about the robes
because this would confirm that at the
point we go to Gringotts we've gotten
our robes
which means
or does it hold on
cause Harry did buy some of his ropes
before he went to school
AJ draws with another Super Chat AJ
thanks for the support plot twist
randrock is the manager of green gods
and Hogwarts owes the bank taxes fig
himself having embezzled the money into
his own magical pockets
I was with you in the first part not
gonna lie
I I think ran Rock could be over
Gringotts I could see that
Hogwarts owing debate taxes Maybe
Maybe
fig himself embezzling the money
starting to get a little bit off the
rails but hey you never know
you never know
121 state of play go check that spot and
then uh or division with another Super
Chat I think the scene where fig and US
releases his palm from the portal and it
turns into the wall
precedes this scene of us in the tracks
of Gringotts
okay or division thank you for the Super
Chat
all right so
let's see what was the timing on it 121
state of play
oh gosh we've got
welcome to the roof 121 yep good call
spot on
with the timestamp okay so they got
robes there
craft and Wizardry with a unique ability
to manipulate powerful ancient dude yeah
so maybe this means they go back that's
what I was saying to Nico I think that
means
or
okay let's think about it this way if
this room
this area right here as many of us have
been speculating this is going to
somehow act as a portal of some sort
where we can get into specific places
into specific parts of of completely
different areas of the Wizarding World
without having to operate
clearly Gringotts on the other side of
the portal here
fig is with us and our character here is
in
School robes great catch both of you
great catch and you do not let's see if
we can see it you're right there's no
school crest
was that Jordan you nailed it Jordan
or no it wasn't Jordan it was um Johnny
Johnny the hustle Russell
nice catch Johnny yeah
okay that's a great point so this scene
right here
I feel like they're at Hogwarts here but
we I guess
I guess we don't even know that for
certain we don't know that for certain
but I feel like they are at Hogwarts
um
and then this happens
okay okay okay
here's another possibility this would
have been really sneaky by the devs if
this is what they did the other
possibility because we've already seen
that you can change out your attire you
can change out your clothing the other
possibility is if is that we've gotten
the timeline all wrong we've gotten it
wrong all along
and that they actually
go to Gringotts much later
and then that that scene that we've been
seeing with our character as I've been
calling it pre-hogwarts attire
actually isn't pre-hogwarts at all
that's another possibility
I'm trying not to like stroke my beard
as much
I was going back and watching a section
of another live stream or something
pulling it from and I was just like dude
I am constantly just like
just over and over
that's gotta like drive people crazy or
maybe it's just me it's probably just me
but I'm gonna try to stop doing it
anyway Neo one thing we know for sure is
that Poppy definitely embezzles uh AJ
definitely think that the Goblins may be
hiding some sort of
ancient magical artifacts somewhere in
green Gods I think so too yeah
can only access via the portal could
totally see that JP says stroke the
beard
could just be their attire they like
from the start yeah like Dustin it
that's kind of what I'm saying with that
second point there it's like they just
you know whatever they did they just
decided
that's the attire they wanted to have on
ropes could just be formal ropes not
Hogwarts ropes
that's what wise Wizards do they stroke
the beard right stroking the beard so I
just thought that was worth pointing out
though that we see this shot of the
character with
Hogwarts robes
and I'm gonna let this play again and as
it goes we can kind of that's the Goblin
from the state of playing 1401 I think
so too Mr tune
the goblin that we appear to be friendly
with
or more friendly with
all right I'ma stop the Spotify music
now
[Music]
trying to think of the best HP Duo to
describe me a new at least she's been
thinking of that this whole time having
no luck who always bullies each other
but are always there for each other
oh maybe like
Sheamus and Dean
uh let's see
I mean kind of Fred and George that's
what I S that's what I started with
Noob with another Super Chat I challenge
all that say Snape is trash
Nico my Patronus is a cat same here dude
this reminds me so much of Zelda right
here
so much of Zelda
would they be a penalty for killing Moon
you guys are off the chain tonight some
comments I'm just letting go because I'm
just like bruh
where Chad is just on another level
tonight man
Chad is on another level
a lot of the things we see in the
background though are shots that we've
already seen before or in other parts of
the trailers but then they just had to
sprinkle those new ones in there you
know just to keep us on
just to keep us on guard like that right
there that's a slightly different shot
more statues here for our buddy James to
break down
then the the unicorn and the werewolf I
love that statue right there in the
middle so again this is like the Hub
area that Boston talked about this area
over here leading into the greenhouse
with the the tree up there in the window
love that
favorite new shot was Professor garlic
feeding a plant right was that a uh
venomous tentacula J Rossi
is that what it's called
oh and I love this shot too so this is
uh Hingis or boy Hingis of Woodcroft I'm
guessing the founder of hogsmead and
then we have these little dancing
candies in the window over here which
more decorations here for hogsmead again
seems like they're in Fall also this
little wreath over here on the right
side
a little the sign pointing out Glad Rags
wizardware this way
this way over here
and yeah I love the little candies right
there hey this kind of looks like the
lollipops that they were using to play
the music
just a little bit just a little bit
there's our boy Angus again
resembled a venus fly trap yeah yeah
yeah
foreign
[Music]
and then we're coming up on
some of my favorite shots
[Music]
and the whole thing right
wait not yet not yet
[Music]
almost there
right here
wait wait I see bubbles in the
background swimming confirmed right is
that what we're getting from this
swimming confirmed
I'm joking I'm joking
oh yeah this is the one from uh the
Sebastian's Dark Legacy trailer
that's not the one I was thinking of
though hold on
okay right here around 3 30 this one
because I think that that one has
something to do with ancient Magic
Leisure not am I the only one who thinks
the herbology teacher could have a
better name look I love her I love her
but
Helen thistlewood
they could have been better than
Mirabelle garlic just saying just saying
we don't know Helen thistlewood yet if
Helen thistlewood is a real character or
not we don't know
but and that I fully admit part of that
just could be because I already had her
as that name in my head and so then
hearing Mirabelle garlic
wait a second no no no no no
somebody else commented on my video what
do you guys think this character is in
the background right there
they were saying it's a new enemy type
and I was just all I can see is
it looks like someone wearing a a
construction hat
whoops
how is it searching right there
right there I mean it looks I I don't
know what it's supposed to be
I see somebody in a construction hat
who knows who knows for sure
okay now we're we're getting to the part
I was I was talking about this right
here dude what is going on here I think
this is in that room that we see with us
and fig
and I'm guessing like remember when
they're they're like walking like the
portal room as we've been calling it
looks like a death puff
Bob the wizard Builder
oh my gosh dude
think Helen thistlewood could still be
real after all Cassandra Mason yeah I
think so too
I think so I think Helen thistlewood is
real just maybe not as uh as an
important of a character
as we were thinking
I wonder if sections of the map change
color to ancient magic discovered
Tristan that's exactly where I was I was
going with this that's exactly where I
was going with this
[Music]
goodness it's just so incredible
I think that's 100 the portal room with
fig
is that at Hogwarts though somebody was
saying do we know where it is I guess we
don't for sure I still tend to think
it's at Hogwarts but who knows maybe
it's it's in that cave that they're
going and exploring maybe they discover
this somewhere else
my guess is still somewhere at Hogwarts
[Music]
oh yeah there it is right there that's
where we
for sure for sure in that room
okay so what can we see here so we got
Hogwarts over here I mean that gives us
a good look at the map which
wife wants a wizard and other creators
I'm sure we'll break down and map this
out overlay it on top of other maps that
have already been created
to give people like perspective on all
of that
but yeah I wonder if like
let's go back again
[Music]
I mean we've kind of got like I'm trying
to look at the different lighting
changes we sort of have like a fog of
War thing going on over here which for
those of you who don't know that term
that's like a tournament open world
games that have like a an area of the
map that's covered in fog that you will
eventually be able to explore but when
you first start there's a fog over it so
you don't really know what's there until
you go and explore it so we kind of see
a little bit of that here and then here
we have like there's this this gold
patch right here your gold right here
but I think that might be more from the
reflections
I was trying to think if there's
anything we could see here to think oh
there's like that's a spot where there's
going to be a big ancient magic
discovery
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I think that that's a slightly new shot
as well the night sky of Hogwarts
oh did you catch that look wife wants a
wizard there you go there's an owl
there's an owl flying away
right there there's an owl
thank you
oh that shot right there so many good
shots in this whole thing
I feel like I've said several times this
is my favorite shot
try to decide which one's going to be my
new desktop wallpaper I've had the dark
arts the deluxe cover as my wallpaper
for so long now
but I feel like I need to change it to
one of these I think it's gonna be the
winter scene the one that I use for the
thumbnail on today's video it's just
it's just so good
especially right now with the Christmas
season upon us
oh the little water wheel back there
this scene right here
I just caught that this shot we see this
spot in one of the uh the ASMR
most emotional part of the score right
here sounds amazing reminds me of the
last three movies yeah for sure
trying to find if we catch any other
there's any other shots
that we hadn't seen before in the game
I don't think so no that yeah then this
one the one that it ends on
that right there I feel like that's
gonna be my wallpaper
that shot is just oh I love it I always
love snow in games anyway it's just like
exploring snowy areas one of my favorite
things to do in games
one of my favorite things to do always
has been oh and a lot of people were
talking about
hold on I gotta back up what do you guys
think this is right here
what do you guys think this is
it almost looks like some sort of little
uh like a battle arena for lack of a
better word dark arts battle arena Maybe
preview for the winter ASMR
100 feathers that's gonna be my favorite
one I already know I already know that's
gonna be my favorite one
Hannah retro rep and Gryffindor oh yeah
got my Gryffindor hoodie on tonight the
zip up Hoodie straight from the uh
Wizarding World Universal Studios
Orlando
dark arts Arena yeah that's what I was
thinking too
so we we know we've got the area inside
of Hogwarts maybe the students
eventually have to move it to another
area the dueling club or maybe this has
something to do with uh
a dark wizard group right
the dark arts battle arena which wait
dark arts battle arena
that's in the but I guess it's only the
Cosmetics that are in the the deluxe
edition right
training area we saw in the previews
poppy ghost oh my goodness Neil oh my
goodness
poppy slander
oh man all right we are quickly running
out of time so let me go all right let
me make sure we are caught up on
everything
make sure we are caught up
gonna check notifications here make sure
we have I mean honestly the news has
been flying so fast
I want to make sure that there hasn't
been anything happen as we've been
streaming tonight
so if you're wondering about the poll
question
this right here is why we had the poll
question can you jump or do does
Hogwarts Legacy have a dedicated jump
button let's check the results of our
poll
if you haven't had a chance to vote yet
in it now is your chance will Hogwarts
Legacy have a dedicated jump button
we've got a 191 votes right now make it
194. 57 okay so our first hundred votes
it was completely tied it was 50 50
right down the middle
right down the middle now
the yes votes have definitely taken the
lead
57 say yes
43 say no uh put me in the no category
I'm saying no I'm saying they were there
will not be a dedicated jump button
I think it's contextual I think it's
based on whether you're near a ledge or
climbing up
um climbing up a ledge or you know like
have a gap that you need to cross
that's my guess
all right so it certainly doesn't seem
like the Hogwarts Legacy news is slowing
down anytime soon we have
The Game Awards coming up
and Hogwarts Legacy is confirmed to be
there
at least in some capacity because we
know they're nominated for an award
we will most likely be live streaming it
right here on YouTube
so it's going to be 7 30 Eastern Time
on December 8th Thursday
we got our little packet as an official
co-streamer I don't know what all that
means if I need to do anything I gotta
look at all the the email the materials
they sent over but we uh the only way
that I probably won't live stream is if
if Chandler or somebody at Avalanche
came out and said they're 100 not going
to show anything new
then I probably won't but other than
that we will and it'll be a different
type stream guys it'll be way more laid
back
we'll just be hanging out watching it
together
and I Keeley has said it's going to be
shorter this year to be honest with you
guys I've never wanted to do this before
because they're just too darn long the
game awards are too long but Keeley has
said this year is going to be much
shorter I mean I feel like two hours is
a good
when they first started I wouldn't say
it was three plus
I want to say it was three plus hours
this isn't laid back Mr Moses well we
just won't have like I'm not gonna come
in with a list of topics that we need to
discuss and go through we had a lot we
needed to get through tonight so I feel
like I kind of had to
Blaze through a lot of things but for
this I'm not I'm not gonna have any
topics when we hop on
it's just gonna be laid back watching
reacting together reacting live
all right I'm gonna go ahead and end the
poll the final results we had over 200
votes here 58 percent
said yes Hogwarts Legacy will have a
dedicated jump button
usually there are only one or two things
I'm actually watching the stream for or
just twitch drops so I'm glad it's short
yeah I know right there's
that's always me as well I am very
curious to see what wins Game of the
Year this year
I haven't played Ragnarok yet but from
what I hear it is a formidable opponent
it better be Elder ringer or Ragnarok if
it's not one of those two I mean my
personal game of the year right now is
Ragnar or is uh is Eldon ring but I
haven't played uh God of War Ragnarok
yet
ah
I still think even after playing
Ragnarok
which I haven't played it yet
but unless they just do something that
totally which I already know the game is
going to be fantastic I already know it
is
but ah man I still think it's going to
be hard to beat out Elden ring
I think it's going to be very hard to
beat out
oh Dr sherbet says new God of War is so
good yeah I mean I've been hearing only
good things and I'm finally
those of you who watch regularly or
follow me on Twitter you know I've been
I I wanted to replay through 2018 before
playing the new one and I was just
planning to go through the story but
I've just gotten so into it I'm trying
to get the platinum trophy now which I
beat all the Valkyries by the way
Valkyries are done what time does it
start right here guys right here
7 30 Eastern Time 4 30 Pacific 12 30
a plus one oh GMT I was like wait what
what is a plus one I have never seen
this time zone in my life GMT there you
go show airs across all major digital
social and gaming platforms around the
world
and of course Hogwarts Legacy is
nominated for the most anticipated game
um I think it'd be awesome if they won
my expectation is they will not because
uh 10 is made up of the fan voting
that's it everything else is
the other 90 is from a panel like a jury
and they're also up against some really
really tough competition they're up
against
um Zelda and Starfield
which to me
Hogwarts is top of my list
follow closely by Zelda followed by and
honestly Final Fantasy 2 is Chris is a
tough
it's a tough competition Resident Evil 4
that'd be hilarious if Resident Evil 4-1
like how old is that game now
I mean I mean I'll play it I'm excited
for it it's one of my favorite games
ever made but
come on
come on
oh there's gonna be a live see I haven't
read anything like normally I'm very
very plugged in on
the gaming industry and what's going on
I just haven't
I just haven't been able to follow it as
closely
mainly because I'm so deep in Hogwarts
Legacy news and I just have to focus
solely on that so yeah I'm kind of
curious to watch and see like what's
going on in the in the industry
but yeah they've got 31 total categories
and even if Hogwarts Legacy doesn't win
I hope that they'll reveal the fan
voting because I would love to see
I would love to see what wins the fan
voting
and I think Hogwarts has a good chance
to win that
although Final Fantasy has a huge
following as does Zelda
never what do you what do I need to
apologize what are you guys talking
about
noobs post said I should apologize for
ruining Alicia's Dream of jumping in
duels
I didn't make the game what do I have to
apologize for
oh my
I'm not apologizing for that
no I'm doubling down
you guys gonna cancel me
I'm gonna get canceled because I didn't
apologize to Alicia
hey thank you Jordan
's siding with me here no need to don't
need to apologize Alicia is a bully here
cancel regulator oh saying that that
made me think um
we need to uh
we were saying we need like uh since
we're calling uh the members members of
house rack and tour we need like a
channel sigil
as well as a like a coat of arms
and a mascot a lot of people were
throwing out a raccoon for the raconteur
mascot
number one Z1 bow one don't apologize
how dare you not program jumping into
the game I know I know
I can't help it Alicia I'm perfect I'm a
victim here
retro do you think you're going to uh
plumb bob receive early access to the
game for being a content creator which
thoughts about that
I would hope so but I have no idea like
I don't know how a WB normally does it
I've talked to a couple of other
creators who have gotten codes before
and
they've said it really just kind of
varies by publisher that some are very
just like they'll give codes to all
kinds of of people great or small
others don't so I don't know really how
WB does it
uh I would love to I I hope so I hope
that I will
and then also
yeah I I don't know I don't know I feel
like
I mean I feel like Chandler and Eric
those guys have been very plugged in
with the community and kind of know
those of us who have been so hyped and
covering this game I feel like if they
have any say like my gut feeling is that
we will
but WB is also a ma is a really big
company it's a really big company so WB
may may have a certain criteria that we
don't meet I have no idea I really don't
I have no idea so I hope I hope that we
do yeah
because it would it would be such a huge
huge help for me with with getting the
content ready because it's just going to
be insane man it's going to be an insane
few weeks the first few weeks of launch
are going to be
just crazy and see what I would love
about it is then I wouldn't have to
worry anything about spoilers at all
I'd be able to get a lot of content
ready and if I if I get the game early
well I shouldn't say if I get it you
know at least two weeks early let's just
say I feel like I could 100 live stream
when when it goes live for you all that
would give me plenty of time to beat the
game
get get a bunch of videos ready to go
yo James uh just a little bit late just
a little bit it's all good though that's
what the vod's there for
Chris off and puff if devs are listening
let retro and other content creators get
the game early hey thank you Chris uh
James James who got to go go to
Avalanche says that they they watch the
live stream guys
he said that that a lot of them watch
I don't know how much of the live
streams you know
if they watch all the way through we're
kind of uh over two hours in at this
point but
but he said that that a lot of them
talked about you know our channel here
um Benjamin snow wife wants a wizard
podcast now wizard PhD of course expecto
go that they that they love this stuff
so they love all the theories
so yeah like like I said no I I think if
I think if Chandler and Eric and the the
Avalanche folks have a say I think we
probably will but again there's there's
a lot of uh
a lot of other people involved when it
comes to WB ooh top commenter
let's see
ever since we started using nightbot
last week
oh
we have a winner
we have a winner for the top commenter
I think you guys should be out this one
this one seems totally
yeah I I can see this one
it's the person you all are telling me
to apologize to it's Alicia Alicia is
our top commenter of the night
congratulations Alicia
maybe they will put just for that just
for you being the top commenter
I will try and use my powers
for good
I'm gonna try right now
to use my powers for good
and make
I'll do I'll do what I can
I'll do what I can to make a jump button
happen
I'm channeling it now
I'm imagining it I'm I'm picturing it in
my mind it's like it's like expecto
patronum you know you've got you've
gotta summon that happy thought
and by the power of Thor's hammer
make it so
jump button in Hogwarts Legacy
dedicated jump button Chandler just to
be clear dedicated
it's not like the game's almost gold or
anything I know you guys still have time
for this so please it's written it's
done there we go
that's it
oh man
she spent the whole night striking
for everyone
dude Alicia just like took the chat on a
journey tonight
she took the chat on a on a journey a
place that I don't know that we've been
before
but we we we went somewhere
and I don't know that we came back from
it uh knew with another Super Chat you
read my other Super Chat I'm gonna make
you hydrate did I read that one Noob I'm
so sorry retro you made Alicia sad
apologize oh yeah that was when I was
trying to figure out why I needed to
apologize that came in Noob I do I do oh
Noob an apology for missing that Super
Chat Noob my fault my friend thank you
for the Super Chat and here's our here's
our hydration
Tater with a super chat and I have to
read the comments since it was a super
chat he is gaslighting you Alicia don't
fall for it
in Alicia top commenter you guys top
commenter
what we gonna do
what we gotta do
nothing Alicia can do to strike fears I
mean nothing oh my gosh Draven don't
tempt her
don't tempt her
get out the hammer Mike says there will
be a dedicated jump button
I don't know
we'll see apologizes immediately to Noob
I'm I legitimately Miss noobs come I
miss Noob Super Chat
that that is definitely needing an
apology
spin faster yes that is where I got this
uh that's where I got this hoodie
actually
that was my one big souvenir when I was
there
which it actually it actually looks
better in this lighting I wish it wasn't
such a bright red I think of the
Gryffindor red as more of a kind of
maroon
maroonish color
but when I have all the lights on this
looks like it's it's much more of a
bright red I prefer the Gryffindor tones
that are more along the lines of uh
kind of like I said a maroon but I still
love it I still love it I used to have a
Gryffindor I think it's a Gryffindor
quidditch t-shirt that was way more
Marooned
but yeah I've been it's awesome I have
not been since they added
since they added Diagon Alley and
Gringotts and all that so I definitely
need to get down there for that
oh my goodness like the the chat you
guys can take this off the rails chat
just take it on over to the Discord
exclamation point Discord in the chat
you can continue it on there even after
the stream is done is it worth it like
uh versus like Disney World
oh yes it for
like I feel like I have young kids so
that's why I kind of hesitated a little
bit for me like for my family we gotta
do Disney World with our kids first
because they they're just but if you're
like I don't know teenager and up I I
like Universal a lot more especially
since they added the Harry Potter stuff
it's awesome yeah definitely worth
definitely worth the trip
moon pies who are you calling a maroon
oh what
oh my goodness
all right so since we are streaming
again this week most likely I'm gonna
cut this one a little short I also have
to be up super early you guys know I'm
not a morning person I am not a morning
person I have to be up super early for
work tomorrow I have to be at
I'm not even gonna say it because I know
as soon as I do somebody who has to wake
up at like 3 A.M is gonna be like well
retro
I have to be up this early
so I'm not even gonna say it but for me
I have to be up very early very very
early
so I'm gonna I'm gonna hop off here
tonight and again unless unless Chandler
or the folks at Avalanche
come out and say we're 100 not gonna be
there
uh we'll be doing a live stream to the
game awards reacting on what is it
Thursday yeah it's Thursday and also
guys the Christmas celebration stream
is happening
lots of giveaways I've been talking with
some people figuring out exactly how to
do these giveaways to try and make it so
a global audience can participate I
think we've got something figured out
that will work I do not have the date
yet so make sure you guys whether you're
a disc or person or Twitter person or
YouTube as well YouTube Community page
as soon as I have the date I will post
there but it is going to be let me pull
up my calendar right here can you guys
see this
so I'll tell you the guy the dates I'm
thinking right now we could just do the
Christmas celebration on the 20th
which would just be a regular Tuesday
stream there's also a part of me that is
thinking about the 23rd much which is a
little bit closer but that's a Friday
night though the Friday night before
Christmas I feel like people will be
traveling be a lot of people traveling
then
so I think like right now I'm leaning
toward the 20th or the 27th one of those
two days
one of those two days will be our
Christmas celebration stream most likely
we're going to have giveaways I'm
working on some other fun fun
interactive things it will not be a
traditional stream there's going to be
you guys will not want to miss this one
let's just put it fast put it put that
way you do not want to miss it only the
hardcore fans will be here if I do the
23rd right
Baxter says 20th sounds good yeah we
could do 20th or 27th 27th I feel like
either one of those
see I'm off work this week
but I'm watching
my wife works like three straight days
this week
somewhere in there
so yeah it'll probably be just how soon
I can get things ready for
20th or 27th will work and what do you
guys think about doing it should we try
to do it earlier earlier like earlier in
the evening
all you guys are gonna say no because
you're here you're the night owls you're
here
oh man
but I there's part of me that wants to
try and do it earlier because there's so
many in the
overseas who can't make a lot of our
streams
it's like 5 p.m that you start for you
Elwyn oh that's why the timing works out
so well for you
nice
but then yeah see then part of me is
like no because I I want to reward you
guys it's really a way for me to get
back to you guys
I want to give back to you guys and I
feel like if I change up too much
then
it would be it would be most of the same
people but I feel like it'd be a
slightly different audience and yeah so
we're probably Gonna Keep at the same
time
Nico and I were trying to figure out how
to do giveaways and twitch actually
makes it super easy to do giveaways so
we were like oh maybe we we could stream
that one on Twitch but it's just not it
just doesn't feel Fair even if it's easy
just to click another button but
I wouldn't want people to have to set up
new accounts if they don't have one so I
think we'll probably stick to 8 P.M
likely going to be the 20th or the 27th
so it would just be a normally scheduled
stream but it's just gonna be like a
Christmas celebration stream lots of
giveaways probably some interactive
games as well that we can play together
on stream
so yeah man and then of course like
whatever happens to the world of
Hogwarts like that's what's gonna happen
I'm gonna plan this and then Hogwarts
Legacy is going to drop like some big
major news that we're gonna have to talk
about
so I'll be putting some stuff out there
uh like I said if you however you prefer
to get your news about the stream
Discord Twitter at retro record tour or
the YouTube Community page I'm working
on something right now that will show
sort of the plan of the stream what
we're doing and I'll post that for
everybody once we have it but yeah man
I'm gonna hop off here I will see
hopefully a lot of you guys here on
Thursday and maybe just maybe
we'll get some Hogwarts Legacy game
award news
and you know what as we go out as we
exit
let's play it one more time my friends
let's play it one more time on the way
out
thank you all for being here
and I will talk to you again soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]